i guarantee the name just put your head
down do the work and everything will
change
sympathy health and fields yeah that's
what i wanted be a patient hello
we are back jimmy we are very very very
back good morning everybody
welcome to a new episode of tea with
garyvee
and i am extremely excited
that was hot uh let's see my steamy tea
um extremely excited to be back with all
of you i hope everybody's been well
i miss all of you please leave comments
give me a little old school like
age sex location uh aol
94 action in here uh let me know where
you're from
uh and and i'm just really excited we
have a
bunch of people on today we're starting
with a good friend of mine i just heard
from mike boyd so i'm excited about that
and then we're gonna go into a bunch of
people from uh
from the discord if you're not part of
the discord we will definitely get that
url up here before it's out
uh but very so there it is nice dustin
it's sharp
this morning dustin you're very sharp
this morning
i was uh thanks you got that you got the
sharp cuts
and you were sharp dust have you been we
haven't seen you in a long time
yeah um good everything's very good
just always chaos but it's
good chaos i think it's been kind of
calm now
i feel like a lot i mean it's been chaos
for me with be friends well yeah
but team garyvee i feel like it's been
chill in a lot of ways no
yeah i guess you're right in the scheme
of things right
yeah having trouble
um there's a little issue on linkedin so
i'm going to check that out
okay uh let me know how that goes um
but let's get uh let's get into the show
let's get into our first guest
yo yo what's good oman gary what's up
dude
it's great to see you good to see you
man it's been a while
it has have you been through all this
been good been good
um you know quarantine's been crazy for
all of us but i i feel we're kind of
going into
some kind of sense of normalcy now um
the big thing for me was i just had a
kid so that's
congratulations thank you seeing it i've
been seeing it
you're excited right it's so exciting
man it really is
i mean she's she i mean it's like
the the stuff they tell you about like
how everything you've done before you
had
your first kid like kind of like you
realize that a lot of
stuff doesn't matter like after having a
kid like
you realize what's important and what
isn't so
it's it's been it's been a wake up yeah
but how are you
dude i'm good bro
be friends is unbelievable dude
thank you my guy it was uh
please you're gonna say i was just gonna
say
you guys crushed it man when i was
talking to um
andy about it and and you know they were
telling me about what you were doing
just it's it's just so like what you say
all the time it's like the perfect
example of what we want to see you know
more of in the nft space which is which
is so sick bro so
you're you're leading the way man i
appreciate it i appreciate it yeah
it's it's been an incredible journey i
mean in general i'm great and
everyone's healthy what else can you
possibly ask for
i think in general i um i've always kind
of been detached
from popularity or
financial success i've been thinking a
lot about that
over the last six months like oh right
like of course you're not going to be as
anxious
or unhappy if you genuinely genuinely
are simple as [ __ ] like truly simple
like
oh i get to like be friends right
you know we're at like 51 million
dollars in sales that's you know it's a
real thing
but if it was 51 so much like if it was
literally we launched it and the market
said go [ __ ] yourself garyvee this is
stupid
like i would have been equally as happy
because the market told me
you know like i have this incredible
relationship with the market
you know i never bring you know i never
blame the algorithm
i never blame that i'm too ahead of my
time and they don't know
i never blame andy or dustin
when you're when you're in a mindset of
accountability and just respecting the
results and just being pumped
that you can [ __ ] do it the process
is very real like
i'm very about that and so for in
general
uh it i'm only i tend to always be happy
as long as everyone's healthy
you know and i i think a lot of people
gain perspective
during cobit but i think a lot of people
are going to lose that perspective in
six months
you know because perspective is a
religion it's not a
moment yeah yeah you got a question
yeah i do actually so um you know
with all this stuff going on i mean we i
feel like we're
kind i hate saying it this way but i
feel like we're kind of like in
post pandemic or whatever you want to
call it like things
we're in a new place we're no longer
completely trapped at home and you know
for those of you tuned in and you are
wherever you're living in the world you
know prayers to you and
and and all that and and you know um i'm
hoping that
things you know normalize a little bit
in time but
but where do you where do you see all
this going man like you know in my
industry i mean you know me and you have
been in the studio together we've spoken
you know years ago before you know
nft crypto online all this stuff
and you've seen the moves i made right
and a lot of the stuff i've done
has been online um in person
so with this new sort of world that
we're entering
do you see the the the hype of the
online vr
ar nft stuff increasing continuing to
increase or do you see more of like
some real world use cases blending in
with both like is this
where where do you think we're headed
right now in terms of just like
being an influencer and doing it online
doing it in person what does that look
like for you
i think that covet accelerated digital
opportunities
it's kind of like a water mark right
like it went up here
as we now go back out you know not every
minute
is on a digital screen so i'll go a
little bit back down here
but it's higher than it was
the the answer is digital and real
are both forever yeah
you know even if we go 100 years out and
we're like just living in that ready
player one [ __ ] life
you still can take the [ __ ] off the
world's like it's still like
you know the outside is gonna be there
like times square is gonna be there is
it gonna be as busy
you know no because there's only so much
time every human's got 24 hours
but what i see is that
all of this continues to bring back more
leverage to the creator
right what i really think in your
business when i look at all those gold
and platinum
records you know the reality is
is a kid coming up in the game now goes
viral on tick tock
launches her or his first album as an
nft and gives up
10 of the monies 20 of the monies to
their audience
instead of a record label own their [ __ ]
their fans make the money not their
distributor because the distributor
snapchat is instagram it's youtube
is the internet it's tick tock so i
think
the creator look look at my world v
friends was actually a lot of people
don't know this two three years ago i
was going to start a toy line
i see all the chats behind you everyone
knows how i roll
i get all these emails from people
saying my boss is a dick i'm really
upset
you know i just got yelled at i hate my
job and i was like [ __ ] people are
really hitting me at work
oh [ __ ] and then i was walking through
my office i'm like man the simpson
stalls the
kid robot i'm like you know what i'm
gonna make something called
workplace warriors this i don't think
i've ever said this publicly
i've got some videos on this [ __ ] of me
like designing the characters with these
toy guys that are incredible ugly dolls
all these people were helping me
and i was gonna make these things called
workplace warriors and
gonna make the little [ __ ] you know
patient panda patient pig and [ __ ]
accountable aunt and empathy elephant
and
the adventurous astronaut and all this
[ __ ] and i was gonna make him into toys
and i was gonna [ __ ] make them in you
know asia
and put them in epic packages and ship
them here and sell them and [ __ ] this
whole thing
and if i did i would have definitely not
sold 51 million dollars worth of
toys by now uh more than half the profit
would have went to
dhl or fedex who shipped over to boxes
walmart or qvc or or fedex
cardboard company 3pls packing and
shipping
the plastic costs money [ __ ] this
then the other thing
and yet you know nfts came along and let
me take that energy
of what i want to put into the world in
a different form that's what's going to
keep happening the creator
the intellectual property creator is
going to keep more of the economics
yeah so i see it i love it man and and
yeah that that's a blessing man i see it
happen all the time that you know you
have an idea and you you think it's the
right thing
and you're about to do it and then like
it never happens and then years later
it's like oh wow like i'm glad that
thing never worked out because it's
smoke i call it smoke i'm always in
smoke mode right i'm always in smoke
mode
i don't have my vr headset here but i'm
always in smoke mode
and then it's time to strike the fire
all right i want to get to a lot of
questions don't mind congratulations i
can't wait to see you
yes sir we'll link soon peace
let's keep this going jonathan what's
good
hey man how you doing i'm well okay good
good to see you
good to see you what yeah i want to say
thanks for uh
over the last year year and a half um
during the covid uh what you've been
putting out there's been a lot of really
really good content
i think has helped a lot of us um it's
helped me
for sure i think a lot of the
conversations you've had
uh over the last little while have been
super inspirational because you bring in
a lot of people from a lot of directions
and you get a lot of different than a
lot of different cross-pollination
so it's really helped us and so yeah
just to start off saying thanks cheers
thank you so much and then from there
and so i work with
leather and i got a small little brand
and i've been doing it since 2012
and started off by myself and actually
to be able to
i was traveling around southern africa
and i was able to
i ran out of money and i needed to get
out of africa so
i started selling small leather things
in the street uh to get my plane ticket
out of africa
just one second one second hey everybody
see in the comments on facebook some
sort of fake garyvee account
talking about gifting it's all [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] scam
dustin do you see it yeah i'm contacting
the team right now just trying to get
them just for everybody's watching like
when you're in the discord anywhere else
i'm never looking for your
etherium i never want your money i never
want your dress
i never need anything don't fall for
that horseshit i'm sorry jonathan keep
going
yeah there was um so basically just
to give an idea it started from this
very very small organic
place and then just continued to grow
and people were showing interest in what
we're doing so
continue to continue to do it and
continue to build a team a small team
but the question really comes from i
have some
really great talents and then there's
some spots that i'm not very talented at
i think that's
you you mean like every other human on
earth for sure
um but the question is as the owner
i find it quite easy to hire someone to
do the things that i know how to do well
you know you just sort of replicate it
you can identify the the talents and
but how do you find people who do those
parts of the business that you don't
actually really know that well
not even uh the profile of the
of the position that well how do you go
about hiring
um by leaning on good friends
and relatives who may know people
in that field and asking for
recommendations based on reputation of
people you trust
it's a tremendous starting point when
you don't know anything right like
if you don't know how to hire an
accountant because you just don't do it
well the first thing you do is go to
your phone and go to literally i think
one of the secrets in life
is the address book in a phone i'm not
kidding i'm super fascinated by it
you know you go to contacts right and
you start with the letter a
and you literally just scroll and what
you find is that c
it says chris conte and you're like [ __ ]
chris was my homie homie homie
and you literally text chris and say hey
chris long time hope you're well hope
it's been
you've been okay during this time sorry
to bother you but like you know
i think i remember you went to
accounting school like do you know an
accountant
it's actually stunning that the answer
to a lot of our questions
sit with a human being inside our
contact list
in our phone
yeah it's so great and right like unity
is everything
right so if you don't know you go to
your phone you go from a to z
and you try to find a human that you
trust
right because that's what you're worried
about i'm like how do i hire i don't
even know what i'm looking for well
you have somebody who you trust tell you
yeah
and then all of a sudden i mean it's
it's the biggest asset
that people are sitting on their
community
um that they're not using
and so that would be exactly how i do it
that's great and then from there um once
you you track someone down and and you
find
the people to hire then this question is
inspired a bit by a comment you made
recently about higher fast and fire
faster something along those lines
i would follow your intuition yeah you
know how does it feel
you know like give me an example in real
life of something that you feel like you
would want to hire for
um
short-term things uh legal stuff uh
helping build structure the business
and that's a really big one for us we're
based in ecuador
i'm canadian so we have work within
canada states and ecuador
um so understanding how that whole uh
right legally taxes all that [ __ ] right
yeah i mean you know i think it you know
on that front
if you get a recommendation from
somebody you trust
you're gonna have to make you're gonna
have to make the assumption that that
person
is good yeah so the only thing then
you're deciding if you don't want to
work with them anymore back to firing
is completely predicated on are they
just horrible as a human being
so it's less about being scared if they
wrote the right contract or gave you the
right advice
right and don't forget you can get two
opinions if you want to be very
thoughtful because you're very concerned
which i think is very valid
you can get two recommendations and then
you decide on
moving forward if you just like and like
enjoy interacting with the person
it's it's i'm telling you right now
drama it's in your address book
you just have to ask six people yeah
i appreciate that cheers brother take
care all right just one quick thing
before you go
um if one of your guys or you could
shoot me a dm i'd love to send you guys
some
some of the stuff we make just as a gift
no
thank you thank you all the best let's
go with it you got it brother
it's great to see everybody in the
comments laura how are you
hope you're a mute rob morrison
hi how are you good how are you i'm good
it's great to see you again yeah it's
been a long time it sure has
yeah so what's the update ah
why don't you give everybody a little
bit of the story so i mean i
went on not thinking about video at all
and you
pretty much checked me to uh you know
i haven't done video in 12 years so i
gave it a shot
and uh i've been doing it ever since
that day
last year and it's amazing i've the
opportunities i've been on a lot of
podcasts
uh my book's been selling more um just
recently i did my first book signing so
at like a teen prevent a teen suicide
prevention
event that was incredible to actually
talk to people
in person to hear people's struggles and
stories in real time and sign it for
their kids
it was just amazing so you know i guess
video was my
thing
it makes me feel really nice why don't
you give everybody like two seconds
of context because i think some people
are freaking out and they're excited to
see
you back on the show but like one minute
for anybody who doesn't know
what's going on what happened you came
on t with garyvee you know the date
yeah 4 8 20. right so a little over a
year ago
yep so i i think i went on saying i've
been writing for 12 years and i said why
are things not popping off
and i said i don't know what it is like
should i not do this anymore
um and then i think you said
well have you done video content and i
said no
and you were like why not and i was like
because i hate it
and then you were just like what the
[ __ ]
and then um so
yeah i mean i just said i was super
uncomfortable i did the video
literally right after that event or that
talk we had
and i've been doing it ever since and it
has gotten easier
i literally did a video i don't know
what time it was but it was four months
out
from our conversation and i said
i in four months twelve years of hating
video was gone
so i have to i'm really proud of you
yeah i'm really proud of you
yeah and it's gotten easier podcasts
have gotten easier
even being just doing random videos just
talking about anxiety talking about
mental health everything
super easy now it's great to see you is
there anything i can
answer for you um yeah i just had a
quick question because
um i had some people who i respect you
know
in regards to my social media and you
know it is traveling jersey girl but i'm
wondering
if i should change the name if i should
make it more
narrow i guess to like laura wiseman or
like author laura weissman
i mean laura weissman is my favorite my
favorite always
is name yeah um you can also go with
laura b
yeah that people used to call me that in
high school
um you know uh
the reason i like very very very narrow
is if you go to laura author
you just might not associate as being an
author you're such a young woman
you have so many more years to impact
and do and live
right and so i've always been a huge fan
of just name
actually i got made fun of a lot not
made fun of jesus like i got razzed a
lot or questioned or
pushed against in the early days because
when i
started garyvee that was when your
twitter handle was like
wine guy gv yeah or like gary wine you
know and i remember
thinking even then in 2006 seven
you know this is just one part of my
life and this whole thing is going to be
huge
and so i i always thought that
i wanted it to be my name and so i i
couldn't be more um
more passionate as well of getting you
to
laura v or laurel weissman yeah i mean
it is just a little sad because i've had
traveling jersey girls since i was 18.
you're you're being romantic about
something that doesn't mean anything
yeah okay get a tattoo
okay you know what i mean like take a
photo and turn it into an nft and then
you can have it
forever but like i if you're asking for
the professional rationale
to more to more upside lord wiseman or
laura v
will work better if you if but guess
what
if you're truly sad for some reason
since you've had it since you were 18
well then and keep it he gives a [ __ ]
what i say
no i know but i'm just thinking like i
just feel like it's not cohesive you
know what i mean because like i don't
travel like i used to
so it kind of doesn't make sense where
it's like
let me let me make this easy for you at
the end of the day it doesn't [ __ ]
matter names are made
right mcdonald's actually sounds like a
corner irish pub in a fourth-tier city
they executed and created the greatest
fast food empire in the world
right nike means dick until phil knight
came along and made it mean something
the [ __ ] is google google's a [ __ ] up
word actually just like anything oh yeah
like google google's a stupid ass
[ __ ] word
you know so but but they made it mean
something so if you know
travel by the way
can be omnipresent travel doesn't mean
physically going to the [ __ ] beach
travel might be the journey your [ __ ]
mindset's going well that's what i say
i'm like this
like because my first book was spiritual
nomad a journey within and abroad so
it's
it's travel but it's really the journey
within yourself so that's
the whole that's the whole thing sounds
good to me
yeah well i just want to thank you
because i don't think i would have
done video after that talk and i've
always told myself i just need that one
garyvee
conversation to do that so it worked
i'm crying laura i wish you the best
thank you so much
by the way in the comments i know google
is a number i mean the word sounds
ridiculous nike's a [ __ ]
greek god i am i know they mean
something i mean they don't mean
something until the like you never
[ __ ] heard
the word google until a search engine
came along and used it i
understand it means something so this
nike so this
so does everything but the execution
is the game not the name people you know
it's names remind me of like that tennis
player that buys like
roger federer's tennis racquet 100
[ __ ] sneakers and has the [ __ ]
headband that does it
and goes out there and gets smoked six
love six love six love because they
can't [ __ ] play
right like the name is not the variable
all right lauren good to see you thank
you
bye bye
hi gary hi joanne how are you
where are you from um i actually am in
berlin but i'm from the philippines
originally
very nice it's nice to see you wow this
is true surreal i can't believe this
is happening it's happening i'm so
nervous my hands are so
cold don't worry what can i help you
with
yeah i have this question because i work
i've been working in a lot of different
companies
um yeah i've been like
um doing like mini jobs kind of stuff
like
um waitress and now i'm in like a
receptionist in berlin
but since last year i actually
like covet came and i saw this time like
we are pushed in this digital world
and i needed to look somewhere else so
i looked back and wanted to
to discover what i have to
um like i can do digitally and
i look back in my childhood and i
actually saw my diaries my diaries are
actually
a comic book of what i was feeling in a
in um in that moment when i was um that
kid
yeah so um now
i i want to do something related to
design and drawings but i have this
weird feeling like
i feel like i need to study before it
but i think i actually have it already
with me
so yeah my question is how to deal with
this um impostor syndrome
i think do you feel do you feel like you
need to study
because you were taught that
schooling was the most important
yeah actually in my family they always
encourage like study because it's really
important and
i yeah in my childhood it was always
like this and
i had this environment like i was always
kind of compared to someone
yeah but yeah it's a bit
no it makes sense it makes a lot of
sense yeah i mean look i
i have too much empathy that you know
three minutes five minutes together
is not going to break 20 years or 15
years or 18 years of
the way you were told it was but you
don't you don't need me
what you're doing with me right now is
just looking for one final check of
affirmation
because even the way you ask the
question you know you don't need the
school you know you have it
even even the way you ask the question
all you're looking for right now
is a little bit of affirmation from
somebody you admire which i'm very
humbled by
and i'm here for it joanne i'm
incredibly ready to tell you [ __ ]
art school you can do this you got this
i'm thrilled to do it
i have better news you you don't need me
you
already know it's why you asked the
question
the way you did but it's somehow
the feeling is there and it's still
like somehow dragging me back but yeah i
know
what's what's dragging you back probably
you might even be using schooling as an
excuse what might be dragging you back
is the fear of it failing or the feel of
people or the fear of people telling you
it's not good
yeah actually that's right
that's what we [ __ ] do on t we break
[ __ ] down emotionally you know like
joanna i would tell you that that that
is
the thing i've spent my life on it's why
i created v friends i want those
characters to help people
um get out of that place like you know
it's it you have to understand
everybody in the comments right now me
everybody in the discords like
if their opinions ultimately don't
matter
it doesn't matter it doesn't
it just doesn't i i would love to pound
that into your head
their opinions don't matter because at
the end of the day
what happens like they're not there with
you
this is your life like you have to make
for you
yeah that's right
right yes so the thing is just be
confident about it
and actually don't even be confident
about it be neutral about it
don't even feel it like
just actually make it because you want
make the goal that you wanted to make it
not how successful it's going to be or
if people thought it's good
right i invited myself sometimes like
okay if
i need to talk with people and
i actually need to feel that
i know what i'm doing or something like
this and when
it's art yeah it's [ __ ]
art when people say my doodles suck
[ __ ] for v friends i understand why they
say that i understand
i understand i just can't value their
opinion
because they are wearing cargo shorts
and i think cargo shorts are disgusting
right like like i adore your
pony what are those called pigtails i
think that's really cool other people
don't
i love wearing a jets hat other people
don't i didn't like wearing
regular like brim hats now i do i wanted
to wear beanies before now i want to
wear this
it doesn't [ __ ] matter
it's [ __ ] art yeah okay
and if i can draw and i can really
design something
but as you say a lot of times um
it might be really neat to have a value
i don't
like okay i can draw but i cannot really
just
give it empty it should
have value value
value comes in a lot of forms right like
obviously with me
friends i was able to do a lot more than
just art
right i i was in a place in my career
where i could throw the conference v-con
where dustin by the way i want the b-con
uh
video to play when we head out um
joanne wright i could i could give
access to me and after
25 years of building reputation 15
really
i people want that however there are
millions of things i bought some nft
teacups
right for several hundred bucks a piece
point one whatever
ethereum because i thought they were
beautiful
that's the value value is subjective
you know an nft can be just the art
and people like having that as a
collectible
and an nft can be something that you put
information
or access or or products or many other
things in the
in the contract but your
self-expression in your art
is value and don't forget you're such a
young woman
in 23 years you might do something that
makes your nfts that you launch today
valuable to somebody so a lot of people
are thinking about launching an nft and
how well it does today
i'm thinking about launching for people
like i would have launched an nft
20 years ago when nobody knew who i was
today
the things i'm doing would have impacted
that nft
so stop what you're doing joanne is
you're living in no
you're living in no you're living in
will they this no i have to do this no i
want you to live in yes
i want everybody to live in yes
everybody lives in no well this won't
happen and this
defense no defense negative what if did
it
did it no no go over here what if it
goes great
and more importantly even if it doesn't
sell or go great
you'll be happy you did it you'll be
happy you need it for you right now
for you where you are in your journey
you need to just [ __ ] make it
just for you that's the win
okay yeah thank you very much for that
you make one you send me an email i'll
buy one
all right okay thank you very much gary
you're welcome
bye-bye let's keep it going dustin
hey gary hey mark are you is it myra
it's myra yeah yeah what's up
yeah thank you i'm were you happy to
talk to you i'm from brazil but i live
in canada now
and shout out to brazil and to the
canadian re-friends because
lots of them talking to me um yeah so
i'm an artist i i do illustrations
and i have like i do it i post it on
ig and i have like a podcast as well
and i'm also like uh working towards
being
being a writer um but
right now i have my nine to five which
is which is fine like i
have like my life and it's good but i do
want to
like um i'm trying to grow like a
community i don't sell anything of my
art or anything like that yet i just
post it and talk to people um
so i'm trying to grow a community and
the goal is to want like to build a
legacy
one day like have an nft project and
um sell some stuff like pro like a
non-profit and things like that and
right now i feel like um i'm creating
the stuff i'm posting it but i
i struggle with some things like i'm not
very
good with video like i don't i don't
show myself very much and
i like even the discord right like i
love it i love the vibe and everything
but
it's like too much energy like it's too
much for me sometimes so i'm just like
i go in and out a little bit here and
there and
yeah i don't know like i'm wondering if
i'm doing something less or wrong
or um no you're you're
you're you're playing the game through
the lens of your feelings
and how you're built you probably
observe
that well if i did these other things
i could build a bigger community
the question is it's a fork in the road
there's a lot of things
that don't come natural to me that i've
fought through
pushed that didn't come natural to me
and i fight for
one was my physical health at 38 i was
like
i'm gonna regret this at 60 or 70. let
me get my [ __ ] together and it comes
incredibly not natural to me like this
morning i canceled my workout
i'm gonna try to do it later because i
just don't ever want to do it but i do
it
because i know it's important another
one for me was candor
garyvee's candaris i'm very good at
candor i'm doing it this morning
but as a leader gary vaynerchuk it was
hard for me to deliver
negative feedback to my employees or
create negative situations
in the last three four years i've really
focused on
kind candor because candor the lack of
it
was hurting me because people were
getting fired and they were surprised
and they were mad at me
it just doesn't work entitlement people
thought they were better than they were
like
so i worked on it what you need to do
now there's many other things
attention to detail [ __ ] attention to
detail i hired 700 people to do that
right um uh i don't like reading
emails so now i make five-minute
meetings i didn't learn how to read
better
right so there's forks there's things
that you have to fight for that you
think really matter
and then there's things that you have to
navigate around
and you realize even if you did it
better you wouldn't be happy
yeah because like i i with my the stuff
i create it's not like super technical
and i know that
like if you compare it to like a an
artist that like
you know like it's not that kind of
thing like i know it's simple and
i know my my vibe with it i like it you
know
yeah i really identified with the
drawings i have a cheerful chipmunk
by the way thank you so yeah i really
identify with the stuff you created
i'm just i guess i'm trying to figure
out how to bring more
value through my stuff so that i can
like really start to build a community
because right now i feel like it's
i started it last year um after the
pandemic and i like
a lot of people and then it's just like
um
it's like it's not like it's staying you
know have you
ever thought you draw it or you
digitally
i draw it on uh procreate um have you
ever thought about have you ever thought
about getting a camera
and videoing you making it and then
putting it on tick-tock behind popular
music
yeah i've done i've done a few of those
i even did one with the cheerful
chipmunk and the peanut butter thing
on it how many times a day are you
posting on
on tiktok i did a few i'm not posting it
often because
i felt like it would be always the same
kind of
thing the problem is i
i've said the same thing for 15 years
and 90
of the world doesn't know who i am yeah
you just said i'm trying to build a
community it's not growing enough and
then in the other breath
you said i don't want to post as often
because it's the same thing
nobody's seeing your [ __ ] yeah ninety
nine point nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine percent of the world
hasn't seen it
yeah post it you should be doing two
drawings a day videos
minimum on tick tock that's how you'll
build a bigger community
all right yeah you you've been around me
long enough to know the rules
you're just not doing it for
reasons similar to joanne prior to you
which is
people say no for no reason yeah i
really
related to what she was saying because i
started as well like not knowing if i
had like the talent to do it but it's
just it's just hard i guess
and tick-tock to not only tick-tock ig
as well like because you post it but you
feel like you're not you know
never never doing enough or it's not
right you know what i mean
it's more it's not that it's you're
looking for results too quickly
nobody watched wine library tv the first
year
i think a lot of times people forget on
shows like this or when i interact that
i lived
the life that i'm giving advice for
yeah for sure
you know people are people see me in
this version
but go look at the comments
on you know episode one of wine library
tv on youtube
there was nobody there
i mean if you go look at the comments of
crush it the first book i wrote
everybody said it was crazy that people
would make money on the internet
being themselves like
negative feedback or no feedback at all
is part of the process
you have to make a lot more content and
put a lot more out
and more things will happen
all right cool good thank you very much
guys
hey guy how you doing good danny how are
you i'm great uh
first off i just want to say thank you
for everything over the years um
i'm a proud owner of confident cobra and
brilliant barracuda
i love it coors yeah of course course
i mean the cores are the ones that have
gone up the most did you buy them at the
floor
so i got one for point five ethan one
for point eight
two e so i i had to go are you are you
are you
the confident cobras [ __ ] yeah bro i
think the confident cobra
it's funny people are buying patient
panda
empathy elephant makes sense right they
know who i am yeah but but there's
but there's a couple of words that are
starting to emerge
in my life that i don't talk to about
enough i actually think the continent
cobra
is one of the sneakiest characters in
all of the friends
yeah i have like serious ambitions to
develop that character
that's why i had to get it at 0.82
because i was scared it would drop
so are you completely freaking out how
much these [ __ ] things have gone up
already crazy but i'm i'm just holding
on so i don't
i i think i have an offer right now for
2.8 eth but i'm not
i'm just letting it ride it seems like a
lot of the cores are going for four and
five like
like yeah you think you've got the you
got the hands to hold on to
at four and five i mean i'm so i'm only
21 so
it's true which is why i'm asking
because at four or five you know all of
a sudden
something you bought something you
bought for you know a thousand bucks and
somebody
two months later offers you six thousand
i have empathy for that that's a big
that's a big turn
i think i boosted the brilliant
barracuda for 10 eats so like if someone
buys it for 10
then i would respect awesome what can i
help you with bro yeah so just to give
you some context
i am a college basketball player
division three right now
thank you i also run my own business
called danny cooper basketball where i
train kids all the way to pros and then
i also took your advice
and i got in touch with the top nba
trainer
and i am interning for him right now so
my question is with all of those things
on my plate
how am i able to like put forth equal
effort and production
while keeping my stress level and mind
even keel
because i know you manage so many
businesses at the same time so like
it's very overwhelming sometimes and i'm
just it's i fear
it's only overwhelming because you're
judging yourself if you're
able to not judge yourself
then you'll be in an incredible spot the
reason i'm
able to do so much is let's say i was in
your position
yeah if if
you know i would look at it and be like
okay what matters to me the most right
now and i would
i'm just making this up i would say you
know i want to be like chris brickley
one day that's what i actually want to
do right now
that's what if you're saying that well
then i would give a [ __ ] about the
internship
more than the club the clients more than
maybe you know whatever school whatever
anything up my personal like whatever
yeah so what i do is while i've got 800
things in the air
you know v friends has been an intense
hundred days for me
i'm aware that i've left some money on
the table with vayner x
there's a meeting i could have went to
right i'm aware that my social media
maybe the garyvee stuff has declined a
little bit i'm aware that i'm aware that
i'm aware of that i'm aware of that but
it doesn't matter this is what i chose
and by the way
in two years i've been like damn i
should have really focused on vcr group
my new restaurant group instead of
defrag
then that's fine too this is one big
game danny about not
judging yourself when you have six balls
in the air
two are gonna fall yeah the
the answer though my man is to be proud
of the four
that are still up in the air instead of
crying about the two that [ __ ]
dropped
yeah and that's the thing it's like one
day i want to be like you said the next
chris brickley but then the next day i'm
like i want to be the best basketball
player i can be so it's
well guess what that's what's awesome
about being 21. no
i know i know it's just it's just hard
like mentally because i'm doing it
once why why's it gotta be hard mentally
why can't it be awesome why can't you be
grateful and be like
i cannot believe how brilliant my life
is
i'm a [ __ ] 20 year old kid i'm
healthy and the world is letting me
decide between being a [ __ ]
basketball player
or a great basketball trainer meanwhile
in the world there's human trafficking
and there's women
in cages meanwhile somebody i know just
lost their
best friend's life meanwhile [ __ ] my
cousin's friend's uncle just died of
cancer like
why why be so narrow
and lack gratitude and why not pop up
your head and say
the fact that i have options the fact
that i live in america the fact that i'm
20 the like [ __ ] bro i would give up v
friends all my money and all my success
to go from 45 to 20 just to do it again
the next one i'd give it i swear to
[ __ ] god if a weird-ass
genie that i drew popped in our meeting
right now and said i'm actually the
genie of the few
and said would gary you can switch with
this kid i wouldn't even think twice
yeah you'd have a lot more money you'd
have a lot more power
you'd have a lot more opportunity but
you'd be 25 years
older and i'd be happy as [ __ ] with my
little phillies pennant in the back
right now
[ __ ] getting focused yeah
why can't why can't you lead into
gratitude yeah so just enjoy the process
and and just
you know that's what you're saying
pretty much just yeah i'm saying be
grateful like [ __ ] dwelling between i
want to be a basketball player or i want
to be a basketball trainer
is the [ __ ] greatest gift of all
[ __ ] time
that's that's what i think sometimes it
just it just is overwhelming at times
but i hear you
so what's overwhelming i guess just
i'm indecisive sometimes so i guess it's
just
so get a dart board in that room yeah
put the two decisions you're trying to
make through put a blindfold on
and [ __ ] throw the dart flip a
[ __ ] coin
i got you you're worried about outcomes
without realizing the outcomes aren't
the interesting part going through it is
the interesting part
yeah yeah exactly dude you're blessed
yeah and they're like really yeah no no
you need to go to
not the quick i know you if you knew you
wouldn't be on this show
asking that question i want you to go
[ __ ] in it
gotcha there was no there was no part of
my life
from 11 to 45 that i would have been on
the askgaryvee show asking or the team
with garyvee asking
because i knew that's what i want for
you
because it feels delicious dude it's
better than you think
yeah it's better than you think
good luck i hope you hope to see you on
vcon appreciate it i definitely will see
you
alright appreciate it
hi good morning gary good morning monica
i wanted to talk to you
i just wanted to say congratulations be
friends it's been awesome to just see it
all unfold
it's my first ft so it's been just a
wild ride so far i can't wait
thank you which one did you get i
actually have a go
the reliable rat you won the reliable
raccoon i did i was number 17.
[Laughter]
and that was just i was beside myself so
thank you thank you so much
you're welcome what can i answer for you
my question i'm a full-time employee
i'm a mom of three i have two toddlers
and an infant it's never a dull moment
here at my house so
i have a very creative side to me i
would love to start like a side hustle
maybe make it into like a business
one day how does one find like their
passion their niche
i have so many ideas in my head but like
to just bring it to fruition
write out right write down all the ideas
and if you've got 17 of them
since 17 seems to be your lucky number
this month
with being the 17th go token do that one
or do what i told danny put all you know
on a dot board dartboard or write them
all down
cut up the papers crumple them up put
them into a hat
pull one out and just do that what
people don't understand
is when they say i have all these ideas
how do i choose one
they're really really hiding
yeah they're hiding here's the thing i'm
a system support analyst so
i analyze processes workflows for a
living so then i start getting in my
head
and i get so far down like the future
that i had kind of shut myself down
before
um and i get overwhelmed right um so
that's kind of my struggle like you said
to joanne i live in
in the know in the world of no and like
what ifs
and until i guess i jump into something
it's
i i just can't make up my mind it's
scary it's very scary
especially being you know a mom of three
you're i think you're worried about
other people's opinions
yeah that too that's for sure that
all the other [ __ ] you just said is not
true compared to
the part we're talking about now okay so
you have to understand
the reason i do well in this format
or like people you know who watch this i
see a lot of first-timers in the
comments being like [ __ ]
how does he know it's not that i know
everything or that
i have intuition and there's just not
that many rules in life
i also like good i'm sorry um like you
say scratch the itch
right so i have a lot of ideas or
inventions i guess in my head and then i
look into it and
it's already out there so how does one
deal with that
i don't want to reinvent the wheel but
there's no such thing as reinventing the
wheel
everything that's ever been big has
already happened
yeah tesla
tesla didn't invent cars netflix didn't
invent television
i didn't launch the first nft project
first is not has nothing to do with you
okay you're you're looking for reasons
to say no
yeah because you don't want to do it
because you're worried about what people
think if it fails
yeah there's nothing i know
100 like you're going to tell me a bunch
of [ __ ] right now like i'm
analytical or i've done the research
you're going to give me a bunch of [ __ ]
that you
are using as makeup
excuses the real answer to your question
is
why are you valuing your parents
your in-laws your siblings your spouse
your children me
the world the discord your friends
social media why are you allowing their
opinions of your actions
to stop you from your actions yeah
i guess that's the bigger question right
that is the only [ __ ] question
when somebody has a ton ton of ideas i
have a ton of ideas i make them you know
why
because if they fail if the friends
failed what
everybody was going to go on twitter and
say i suck i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not worried about other people
deciding if my shit's good
the [ __ ] are you worrying about my [ __ ]
for worry about your [ __ ]
yeah i'm not out here looking at
everybody else's [ __ ] worrying about
what they're doing
get inside your own [ __ ] world okay
your entire thing and many people's
things
and the theme of this morning is
being able to not worry about outside
validation
too many people were parented and grew
up in circumstances where they lived for
outside validation
outside validation is poison it leads to
insecurity and non-action you know what
else it leads to
ego one of the most beautiful things in
the world is humility
do not you know i always tell people do
not confuse my conviction
and my passion for for lack of humility
i'm pure humble you know why i don't
think everything i'm going to do is
going to succeed
i'm pure you know the other thing is now
that i'm at this point in my career
where everyone's saying all these lovely
things about me in the comments
they don't make me think i'm special i
don't think i'm more special than any
[ __ ] person in this chat right now
i don't i'm and i'm not saying that to
like
say it i just don't believe it i don't
believe it
and and that's the other thing that
comes along that's beautiful about not
hearing everybody
when they say you're [ __ ] you're not sad
when they say you're great you don't get
a big head
absolutely stop monica stop who what's
what are they gonna say that's stupid
you know what people are gonna you know
what
do you know who tells you the people
that tell you negative things about your
thing
are just people that are sad that
they're not doing it
yeah no that's true it's true because
when i do do something then they start
asking oh
how where'd you you know how'd you do it
i get it
please just do it okay all right see you
got it thank you
you got it nice
hey gary how are you i'm well tim how
are you doing great man i'm just
thankful for everything that you guys
do all the content everything that
you've been creating man i've been
following you
like i'm like man this is the
inspirational [ __ ] that people need
um so just i'm gonna start with uh
thanks i mean long time listener first
time caller if you will thank you
yes i love that but i mean the v friends
piece
just the engagement the community that
you've built around that that's been
phenomenal but um how crazy is the
discord
i have trouble just tracking like i'm
always like when you do the at here i'm
like oh i gotta go find that and i gotta
and i'm like strolling and it's
refreshing and i'm like
dang this phone it's not moving fast
enough i need 5g or some kind of upgrade
i need this to like work better
but do you have any be friends i didn't
get in on it man
i i missed out and i'm like i really
should have jumped in
a lot earlier but i was watching i'm
like trying to figure out what did you
what
what what do you think held you back
could you not afford it did you not
trust
the blockchain ethereum did you think
the prices would go
down none of it hurts my feelings i'm
trying to learn and i want people to
learn like what what do you think made
you
not go in i think it's more just
personally i'm
ultra financially conservative i wanted
to be in on it and i wanted to do that
but then i was like looking at the
ethereum prices
and i didn't buy at ethereum like early
enough you said hey
may 5th and i was like man i really
should do this but it was just kind of a
thing
it was it was too far-fetched you hadn't
been into crypto
you didn't you know you hear the horror
stories you started falling into the
nose of like
it may collapse this might be a fad you
know my stuff might get stolen like it
was all that kind of nope
that no culture right right right just
by the way
and by the way for everybody's listening
i actually think you should never do
something you don't understand
one of the reasons i put out content
early
as you know was i wanted people to get
educated
because i wouldn't want them to buy be
friends i don't want them to buy me
friends right now
if they don't understand if they don't
understand that i'm trying to build
transformers pokemon star wars
and that the nft just like the first
copies of harry potter the book are
worth lots of money
like you know or the first star wars
figures or you know
so i don't think you tim you made a per
se mistake
you know i know that a lot of people
feel crazy because they've gone through
the roof in value very quickly
but things have been flow and more
importantly you know
i i don't think people should do things
they don't understand with money i never
do
um on the flip side i don't think people
should say no before they do homework
you know so there's a nuance there but
nonetheless what can i help you with
well so my story i'm an engineer by
education and
i've been kind of moving around within
my company and i do
like what i'm doing i just feel like i'm
kind of stuck on
hey i'm in my late 30s my resume doesn't
really speak to
where i'd like to go and i'm you know
i'm just like carpet bonding companies
on my resume right now
hey like this is where i'd like to be
good um i try
to like tell people like this is who i
am this time
you know what i got you you have to
start making
linkedin posts video or written
about your observations thoughts and
opinions of where you want to be
okay because you may say one smart thing
about social media marketing in a
linkedin post that
makes somebody reach out to you to hire
you as you know or
rowing or t or whatever the [ __ ] you
want to be in
like you have to start making content on
linkedin today
with your observations and opinions and
thoughts
about the thing that you want to be in
yeah i think it is you know just
starting to get the content out there
get in front of that and like really
what what what what
spamming carpet bombing
pounding resumes to people on linkedin
or email
is begging asking
hoping making content on linkedin
that's grounded in strong opinions
observations thoughts
because you don't have to be an expert
because right right
or expertise that's being proactive
that's putting it out there that's
creating leverage
for them to come to you got it right
right
right get ahead very different frame
different framework
yeah keep the hat on the head not in the
hand right correct
i like it all right correct thank you so
much for your time i appreciate being
able to get on here appreciate it
brother all right dustin i got to go to
my next meeting
let's uh let's get you on for one second
it was good to get back
yeah um your energy is good too yeah it
was fun
let's uh let's everybody's watching
first of all
please get on the discord you saw it
referenced a lot it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable what's going on there
everybody's watching right now if you
can
if you can link this in the chat so it's
clickable for the others
we need people to get in there makes it
much easier if you can link garyvee.com
discord in the chat right now whatever
chat you're on
make it linkable because i know a lot of
times when you click
post it it's not linkable please go
hardcore make it easy for your fellow
friends
uh and remember every v-friend token
comes with a three-year pass to v-con
uh and dustin's about to play the v-con
trailer vikon is going to be
the greatest thank you dust thank you
everybody
please let me know on twitter garyvee on
twitter how today went
what you thought about it how it felt
what you got out of it
and uh we'll talk soon cheers
this is an unreal level of access to you
for people who buy these nfts
yeah i mean wait do you see what i'm
gonna do with the conference this could
be the best conference of all time
welcome to v-con v-con
is a yearly event that is tied in
directly
to the friends the nft project that i
launched in may
of 2021. every befriend
token is a ticket to a multi-day event
that is going to rival some of the
greatest conferences in the world around
entrepreneurship marketing ideas
creativity competition tons of jam
sessions
all night marshmallow pits talking
meeting
surprise and delight the community you
know i live a career where i've been
able to travel the whole world
and see all the greatest conferences and
that decade of collecting oh i like this
so i like how they did that that was
epic and i like how the unconference in
the hallways this and oh the best part
of a conference is who you mean i'm
gonna bring
all that my main plan is to leverage my
25-year career
and all the karma and all the
relationships and all the business stuff
that i've done
to bring the world's greatest speakers
there and i also have the privilege of
being in the dirt
right there drock show it like the dirt
i like i like that [ __ ]
i'm from that [ __ ] so i know the kids
that are coming up the game right now
that are the next people that are gonna
matter
and of course i'm gonna have them
headline side stages
so that you can meet them early and
build relationships with them early and
do business with them early
and have selfies with them early but i'm
also going to have the
biggest names in the world because i'm
going to take the profit
from the drop and i'm going to invest it
in throwing
the conference that i've always wanted
to attend
be gone